kopi Brian and when you think about his
legacy as an NBA all-star you look at 18
appearances which is second only to
Kareem who had 19 you look at for
all-star game MVP awards for Kobe Bryant
which is tied with Bob Pettit for the
most and when he played in the all-star
game in 1998 Kobe was 19 years old the
youngest to ever do it here now a look
back at all-star memories of Kobe
[Applause]
[Music]
and when you plan an all-star game you
view that means you're one of the best
players in the world
[Music]
arrested our own people go insane
[Music]
[Applause]
I have a fun but the fun is in the
competition's doing we do better
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
man with the ball right there is
zipping around of players so many great
players about here just give the chance
to talk to talk a little trash
[Music]
[Applause]
alright good I can run you a little bit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's trying to see him just trying to
dunk on me
you lit up at the edge it started
dumping me Craig
[Applause]
I'll try getting a good a robot anyone
do it this is all miss that that
interaction and the competitiveness as
well surely yes
we're gonna go for the slammer
[Music]
now has his fourth all-star MVP Kobe
Bryant walk around was pretty cool my
first all-star game use and the
nutrition no doubt only time I've been
nervous for game is 98 it means the
world since this is my first all-star
game playing in New York City with all
these great basketball players is
incredible experience
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when I was a kid watching the all-star
games I've always wondered so we went on
behind the scenes to the players do
privacy please slow motion and now to be
a part of it you kind of know the ins
and outs and things you know what goes
on and then it's fun I'm still like a
kid in the candy store when I sit back
and watch so many great players good
mass time playing there the crowd got me
real pumped up after that don't so you
know anything I felt like doing was
flexing
[Music]
we gotta go through the intro so say
well my mind I'll come back out okay
we'll go pick up on that stage over
there you take the bar with you 18 time
[Applause]
[Music]
that's just been extremely fortunate to
be able to play the game without love
but I leave now he's older
[Applause]
the element it's a thrill for me to be
here in this all-star game get a chance
to be around these young players here be
able to speak to them about the game
share somebody knowledge that I've
learned throughout my career and so that
they can carry on the tradition of the
NBA want to thank you guys
[Applause]